[Applause]
i feel like i am the envy of the room
please welcome sam hewitt oh thank you
nice to see you
it's so nice to see you
i just scrolled
okay good i'm like i just drooled there
goes my cool
um i blow it every time it's it's it's a
better place to just start from reality
right yeah yeah the base reality i
drooled
yeah
get to know me right yes
actually there are people who already
know you in the audience we have some
heligens yeah
i mean
how fun how crazy it's it's so nice and
it's so nice to have the fans here and
and we've had this huge drought lander
it's been you know roughly on outlander
and now we're finally back on maybe you
need a drool lander
um okay it is design week on the show we
are talking all things design all right
okay do you have any design
loves or dislikes any design loves or
dislikes um i i i recently moved house
actually in scotland and i have this old
tavern that has been done up and so i
love it it's do you live in an old
tavern i do which is probably quite
fitting for me to be honest i did a deep
dive on your instagram and you are all
about
the spirits
not not the ghosts no yeah the imbibable
revivable ones yes i have a whiskey
brand and we recently uh released the
tequila as well
and
you are everywhere with your best friend
and in kilts and i heard you love a kilt
i do i have to ask you do you wear it
traditionally
what do you mean by that
you know
it's a little breezy it's uh yeah that's
i heard that's the traditional way to
wear a kilt it is it is
it's liberating um
riding a horse in a kilt can be
interesting but um it's uh no it's great
i've just come back from new zealand
i've been shooting my uh travel show men
and kilts and my good friend gray
mctavish we uh we do obviously wear
kilts well and we wear them
traditionally and we may do
i'm in a skirt right now and i cannot
imagine are you tradition i don't even
know i don't even know why i'm asking
you guys
but you can't i can't i'm allowed to see
it like underwear oh
you're crazy what's wrong with you i
don't know yeah you're doing it all
wrong i'm starting to rethink it yeah
you should i have two daughters though i
would literally not allow them to ever
wear a skirt with no underwear so i
guess that's the problem well see the
kilt is is very heavy material okay and
there's a lot of fabric there's still a
giant open vent i mean what happens okay
what happens if you fall
and i don't know either that or
when i fall it's like i eat it i roll
you know well actually the scots they
used to go into battle and they would
they would take their kilts off and
sometimes just run into battle just in
their shirts like just to scare the
opposition
or to
thrill the opposition i don't know like
how do you yeah how how does one keep in
battle if you're like
just completely nude yeah i'm not sure
yeah i haven't tried that one drew but i
might in the future there's there's a
common theme here i'm beginning to see
but uh yeah
[Music]